- Awesome.
Thanks everyone for coming out today.
My name is Vishal.
I'm the product manager
for EC2 Mac at AWS.
I'm super excited to be joined today
with two of my customers that
I work very closely with.
We have Miranda from Riot and
we have Toni from Supercell.
And so super excited for
you guys to hear from them
as well about how they
use EC2 Mac to help build
and test their own applications
for their organizations.
So I'm going to kick us off today
with a little bit of
the history of EC2 Mac
and specifically, how we
came about EC2 Mac on AWS,
what are some of the big pain points
and key struggles customers
told us they faced,
how we, at Amazon, use EC2 Mac internally
and then we'll actually pass
it over to Miranda and Toni
to actually give us insights
into their own organizations
about how they've implemented EC2 Mac
and some of the benefits
that they've seen.
Cool, I'm just going to make sure
that everyone can still hear me all right.
You guys good? All right, awesome.
So let's take a little step
back around understanding
the application development
lifecycle for Apple platforms.
In the earlier stages,
we have the design,
code and develop stage.
These necessarily aren't macOS-dependent,
but as we go into the
build stage and onwards,
you need Xcode, which everyone knows,
Xcode needs to work on Mac hardware
and that unfortunately means
that you absolutely need to
buy Mac hardware and scale
as your applications increase as well.
So it's this dependency
between Xcode and macOS
that made Apple development
on any hyperscaler impossible
until we introduced EC2 Mac back in 2020.
Today, the total market
for this opportunity
is well over 34 million developers,
many of you who are sitting in this room
or will be watching on
YouTube when this gets posted.
And the last time I made this deck,
I think it was about a million apps.
I think that we've now scaled
to 2 million apps on the App Store
and more than 2 billion
active devices as well.
And Apple's introduced
a lot of new platforms,
including visionOS that came
about a year or two ago.
And today, with EC2 Mac, we
have customers across the board,
different industries, different functions,
building, testing and
developing applications
for each of these platforms.
I want to share with you today
some of the key struggles
that some of our customers told us
when they were giving us
feedback around EC2 Mac
and the business case
as we start to do it.
The first thing was
infrastructure overhead.
Miranda's going to talk a
little about this in the future,
but I'm super excited to talk to you guys
about how the actual
ability to go and deal
with physical hardware
in their data centers,
customers absolutely hated it.
They had to drive multiple hours,
fly to different data centers, unplug,
deal with data center technicians,
all that headache cost time,
money and other resources.
Pinterest here give us
a really good quote here
around how the physical challenge
of actually going to physical data centers
was a real big struggle for them
and that's one of the big
reasons why they use EC2 Mac.
The next thing was the actual inability
to go and have automatic fleet management.
Groupon here told us about
this definitely increased
the time for their time to market
and every time something went wrong,
they had to get IT involved
and this was a really big struggle
that they've solved by moving to EC2 Mac.
And the last thing was inability to scale.
Sometimes your workloads require
less number of resources,
sometimes they need more.
We see a lot of customers on the weekends,
maybe, not having as many builds or tests,
so they scale down and then
they scale back up on weekdays.
This was one of the big benefits
that iQVIA saw in EC2 Mac
and how they are optimizing using various
different resources
like Auto Scaling Groups
to come into EC2 Mac.
All in all, this reduces time to market
and essentially slows down
innovation for your organization.
So this is where we brought in EC2 Mac
back in 2020 here at Re:Invent actually.
So this was the picture that
we always use for EC2 Mac.
As you can probably tell,
this is a 2018 Intel Mac Mini,
which was our first ever Mac hardware
that we retrofit in our AWS data centers.
These are connected with different PCIE
to thunderbolt cables and we essentially,
this is an example of one droplet,
as we call them on AWS, but
essentially, it's one server.
And so when you, as a
customer, use EC2 Mac,
you have the full access
to the underlying hardware
offered by Apple as
well and what they have.
So essentially, the PCIE
to thunderbolt connections
allow us to do implement with AWS Nitro.
So that gives you all the
networking and EBS bandwidth
that you get and enjoy
with the rest of AWS.
And so our engineering teams
had to do a lot of manual work
to make sure that Apple
hardware works with EC2 hardware
and we've even gone in so far as some
of these older platforms actually
even have robotic fingers
that actually press and
hold the power button
to turn the machines on and off.
So it's a lot of huge credit that I give
to my engineering teams to
go in and build the patents
and everything that's needed
to operate these machines.
But this photo's too outdated.
So I decided to bring in some new photos
and today, here we see, some
of these are our M2 Pro, M2
and the most recently announced M4
and M4 Pro Mac Minis as well.
And this is exactly how it
looks in our data center.
So on the upper left-hand
side, you can see
that the form factor
remains about the same.
We still have PCIE to
Thunderbolt connections,
but the Mac has changed.
As you know, the M4 and M4 Pro Mac minis
have gotten almost to the size
of an Apple TV essentially
and as many of you know,
the power button has gone to the bottom.
So there was a lot of engineering needed
to make sure that the same
hardware functionality,
the reboot mechanisms, all that work.
So some of these slides,
you might not be able
to see it on the screen,
but the M4 and M4 Pro also,
which we announced, I think,
on September 12th come
with new internal SSD drives
that a lot of our customers are using.
I know Miranda and I talk
a lot about this as well,
but this is something that we've added,
it's not really visible
in the pictures here,
but it definitely gives
customers a lot more performance
for local caching mechanisms as well.
So want to just quickly cover
why customers continue to use EC2 Mac
and continue to stay with
EC2 over the course of,
now what's going to be, about six years.
So number one, one of the pain points
that we talked about earlier, with iQVIA,
Groupon and Pinterest
was they really wanted
to improve their automation story.
And so without going
to much of the details
around every single spec that we have,
we've now built automation
for some of the highest
requested features that customers have.
This includes the ability
to disable and enable SIP,
which many developers need
to test their custom code.
And for those that don't know,
SIP is System Integrity Protection.
It's one of the most painful things
about working with Mac hardware and macOS.
And so our engineering teams have done
a really cool job to do.
So just a little look behind the scenes
of what SIP actually involves.
We actually have custom software
that goes in and mimics
what a mouse movement
and GUI interaction looks like
when you actually click in on a user.
And so every time we change
a particular macOS version,
we have to make sure
that that microservice
that we actually have is able to recognize
the newest GUI elements.
So for example, with the
latest release of Tahoe
that we just announced a few weeks ago,
liquid glass made
everything very tough for us
with different pixels,
different placement.
The way that the user icon
actually shows up on the screen.
Our engineering teams had
to spend a lot of time
to rework everything to
make sure that it works
and meets our security standards.
So SIP is just one of
those example features
that we've had to do a lot of effort on
to make sure that it works as effectively
as it did on Sonoma or Sequoia before.
We talked a little bit about operational
efficiency struggles that
customers had before.
One of the big things that we
introduced a year or two ago
was the ability to integrate
with Image Builder on AWS.
And so customers today
have both Intel machines
that run on x86 AMIs but then we also have
Apple Silicon AMIs and
they've been able to use that
for using various different
services like Image Builder,
but you can also use Packer and whatnot
to make your custom images.
And then a few years ago, we
introduced replace root volume,
which allows you to kind of provision
fresh new macOS environments very quickly.
A lot of customers also have
a very important monitoring
and logging story and so obviously,
CloudWatch is natively integrated,
but then we also have other integrations
with other monitoring services.
And lastly is everything is
secured through your Amazon VPC.
And so with IAM controls, access,
it works just like any other
EC2 instance that we have.
I'm excited to share what
we've delivered this year.
Firstly, we talked a
little bit about this,
but M4 and M4 PRO are now GA,
have been GA for about
two and a half months now.
We have a really cool video on our website
if you guys want to go
check that out afterwards.
We also improved our resiliency story
by introducing support for
dedicated host auto recovery
and reboot-based migration for instances.
Hardware will fail, as our CTO
always says in our keynotes,
but essentially, anytime it does,
we've now introduced
better resiliency measures,
so that your instances can
reboot onto other hardware
and you don't need to
worry about maintaining
that transition of when an instance
or a hardware goes down as well.
And going back to number one here,
we talked a little bit about
why I want to point out
the two terabyte instance
store volume is historically,
Apple gives us an internal
SSD, but unfortunately,
due to the way that we do
our terminations and reboots,
if something goes wrong, we won't be able
to capture that data and
move it to another instance.
With the two terabyte instances,
sorry, local store volume,
we're essentially giving you more space
for your caching mechanisms,
all at no additional charge
to what we have organically
with our pricing mechanisms with EC2 Mac
and this has been one of
our biggest customer asks.
You still can use EBS volumes,
but this is essentially
free storage for you guys
to go and optimize using your AMIs.
Just, I think, two weeks ago,
we introduced Amazon
DCV support for EC2 Mac.
DCV, you may know it as
Amazon DCV previously.
It's a high display resolution protocol
that can give you up to 4K resolution
when you access Mac instances via GUI.
And so this is currently free
to use and is GA as well.
So a lot of customers have been using DCV
for better simulator-based
testing or unit tests for any
of their applications
that need a GUI interface.
We delivered, as I said,
System Integrity Protection
configurations earlier this year
and obviously, most recently,
we did deliver macOS 26
as Amazon Machine Images as well.
So here is the current lay of the land
around where our platforms are today.
You can see we continue to support Intel.
Oops, we continue to
support Intel Macs as well.
As we all know, Apple is
transitioning away from Intel,
but we still support those
with Sonoma and Sequoia images.
Oops, and then along with
the latest M4 and M4 Pro,
which now comes as two terabytes discs
and highly recommend you guys to tune
into Matt Garman's keynote
tomorrow for some additional
future announcements as
well coming on EC2 Mac.
So super proud and also happy to share
that these are all just
a handful of customers
that are using EC2 Mac today.
As you can see, there are customers
across different platforms,
across different industries, verticals
and we have a good selection
of partners as well
that we can help you with to make sure
that you get the right and
best usage out of EC2 Mac.
So at a high level, these
were some of the benefits
that customers have shared with us
and this is also available
on our public pages.
I think the one that really speaks to me
is the reduction in build time
as well as the reduction
in build failures.
This is one of the biggest
reasons why customers continue
to come to EC2 Mac is because they view
the entire AWS ecosystem
with the networking
and the resiliency measures
to be one of the best,
compared to a lot of our customers
have had their own data centers go down
and so they are like,
"I never wanna face that challenge again."
And they come to AWS and
they have been very happy
with the way that the resiliency
aspect of it especially.
I think all in all, we continue to invest
in this platform very heavily.
Looking forward, we're
continuing to always look forward
and to support the latest MAC hardware,
increase our regional
availability, increase our global,
just in general, global
availability of Mac hardware
across different types and as always
and as a product manager,
we always work backwards
from the customer.
So if any of you have feedback and,
or interest in trying out EC2 Mac,
there's no room, time
for Q and A on stage,
but I'm happy to chat with
anyone afterwards as well
to discuss your interests
and how we can get you
started with EC2 Mac as well.
With that being said, I'm
super excited to pass it off
to Miranda, who's going to
talk to you a little bit
about Riots Game with EC2 Mac.
- Hi, I'm Miranda Pearson.
I'm an IT systems engineer
on the IT infrastructure team at Riot
and we support the build farm
by providing infrastructure
as a service to those teams,
so they don't have to
think about build infra
and they can just focus
on what they do best,
building games.
This journey, we're going to
start from our starting point.
We're going to work
through the journey we took
to get there, how we
rebuilt, the choices we made,
what we got out of that and what's next.
At Riot, just to give context,
we use Apple Development workflows
for three different things.
We use them for signing workflows,
game builds and audio asset processing.
Those three workflows
have different shapes,
different requirements, different needs
and that ultimately shapes
how we meet those needs
with EC Mac.
Our story starts in Vegas,
actually at Switch Datacenter.
We had a pool of about
60 hardware Macs on prem.
We were losing about 2% a year
and we were plagued with issues.
So let's dig into that.
We hit the limits of what
we were able to patch out,
performance-wise, when
we started coming up
against the constraints
of the data center design
and the custom mounts that
we had to use in that space.
That was actually a picture
of our on prem fleet,
the cheese graters in the
rack on the previous slide.
And this next one is also the trash can
from our original on prem fleet.
We had drives literally melting,
not an exaggeration at
all, literally melting,
VMs kept running, if storage
was gone, we didn't know
until someone else told us they were gone
and the builds weren't working.
Doing one set of repair took
away about 8% of the fleet
every time we had to repair.
Next, we'll get into the forcing functions
and the pain that pushed us into a point
where we had to do something about it.
As we talked about earlier,
the heating, cooling, I/O,
storage, compute limits were being hit
and that was trickling
down into developers,
which impacted build times,
which impacted build velocity,
which impacted the way we were able
to deliver games and changes to players.
The biggest pain for
our team was the on prem
physically being here
to maintain our stack,
to do a firmware update, to
do a patch, to do a quick fix.
We had to get on a plane and actually come
to Vegas to do that.
And all of that just became unsustainable.
The first trigger that started our journey
was that Riot made the call to get out
of data centers as a business.
We were no longer going to be
maintaining on prem hardware,
so we had to start the
journey of moving out.
The second was a forcing
function of a security incident
that required us to rebuild
completely from the ground up
and we couldn't reuse any of
our original infrastructure
and we had to rebuild in a safe space.
So AWS was a great landing
spot for us for that.
Another issue was future incompatibility.
We were on VMware at the time
and ESXi 8 was dropping support for Mac,
so we also had no choice.
Pretty much speaks for itself,
but we hit the breaking point
where it was not going to
scale for us to get on a plane
and physically come in
person to maintain a fleet.
That wasn't going to scale with
the workflows and workloads
of developers that are building games
and experiences for players.
Next we'll get into how we rebuilt.
EC2 Mac was our savior.
AWS had our back with the capacity
that we couldn't get easily on-prem.
We were able to stretch
and expand that as needed
and we no longer had to get on a plane
to come here and physically
maintain our infra.
So the turnaround time for
lifecycle was a lot more smooth.
We were able to automate things.
Terraform became our lever to get out
of our trashcan trauma cycle
and turn our physical fragility
into something that we
can maintain as code.
For our customers, the journey starts
when a customer submits
a PR to a GitHub repo
that triggers Jenkins to run a build
to do a Terraform plan to
provision those resources.
Once that plan goes into place,
it starts to pull in an AMI,
which is maintained by
our product security team
in a centralized account
and shared out with customer accounts.
So once that Terraform
hits the customer account,
it'll use that AMI, which has
our baked in certificates,
security features and basic tooling
that product security mandates
for our production workloads.
In that account, once it's
launched or sorry. (chuckles)
Jenkins uses STS to
assume a centralized role
that we share and maintain,
so that teams don't
have to do that locally
in their accounts and there's a codified
representation of that access.
With that temporary credential,
they're able to go into the account
with that secure base AMI,
launch the instance in the account.
And then from there, we have
event driven automation,
which will pick up, oh hey,
there's a new instance,
I should bootstrap it or
do whatever it needs to do
in response to that new
instance spinning up.
If there are any failures
there, that will go down
to CloudWatch and we'll get notified.
The bootstrap is done via Lambda
and we're able to do deterministic
and dynamic bootstrapping with SSM.
The SSM documents are
maintained and shared
from a centralized account as well,
which is a tooling account.
And those are shared down
from our customer accounts,
so that we can maintain
a single source of truth
for those bootstrap
documents, patching documents.
So what changed after we
made the lift and shift?
Our first shift from on
prem Intel to EC2 Mac Intel,
3x our primary build time,
signing increased by 2x
and code build, two-and-a-half.
Just the mirror lift and shift,
we were able to get rid
of a lot of the noise
that we were seeing with
on prem hardware failures
and really see the signal.
Our first shift after migration
was to move to Silicon.
We chose and we elected to do a hardware
and software upgrade at the same time,
which was able to amplify our gains
and get us faster, cheaper, better
scalable infrastructure
for our build teams.
For us, fleet diversity isn't
just an exercise for fun.
We have a lot of different
shapes of workloads
and these are how we map the
shapes of those workloads
to the different EC2 Mac instance
types and when we switch.
And the greatest thing about
EC2 Mac that we get now
is that teams don't have to lock in
to a specific instance type.
They're able to evolve as their workloads,
as their workflows do, as pipelines do
to meet the needs of
what those builds are.
So something like TFT, for instance
or Unreal might rely on M4, M4 Pro
and we're continuing to see how
to evolve our fleet for that.
Where we're going and what's next.
As we continue to evolve
and operationalize,
optimize our fleet, our next steps are
to explore shared capacity
to see how we can make,
have that capacity feel
more elastic for teams
rather than being tied
into a specific node.
Switching more of our ARM
workloads to M4, M4 Pro
to get better performance,
to get increased build throughput,
asset caching, because we have huge-
One of the biggest issues we face
is that we have huge per force depots
of about two terabytes for a build
and those can get really size-heavy.
So anything that we can do to cache
those assets ahead of time makes it easier
for build engineers and developers.
Finally, we want to
explore unlocking better
storage bottlenecks by using local NVME
across different workloads.
Now that I've shared our
journey about what we've done
with EC2 Mac, I'll hand it to Toni
to talk about how Supercell
did the same thing
a slightly different way.
- Excellent, thank you, Miranda.
Let's go into looking into
a little bit different.
(chuckles)
There you go, Miranda.
(audience clapping)
So let's next take a
look what Supercell did
in terms of the journey to using E2 Mac.
Supercell is a fitness-based
gaming company,
well known for Brawl Stars, Clash Royale
and Clash of Clans, of course.
And we kind of had the whole
similar sign type of thing.
We didn't escape from a Nevada desert,
we escaped from our own basement in fact
where we had a lot of
Macs running the same way,
those cheese graters
and all the other stuff.
My name is Toni Syvanen,
I'm a senior cloud governance
engineer working for Supercell
and first off, I want to
acknowledge on this presentation
that my colleague, Jani Munen Mackey,
who actually led the
creation of this solution
and also created this
presentation as well.
And my part in this was actually
work on the architecture,
then working out on
troubleshooting the problems
from the setup itself.
But as a background, we had a lot
of those Intel-based
Macs downstairs as well.
And a lot of these teams,
what we call cells,
hence the names Supercell, are
really, really independent.
So each of those teams
had their own hardware
that our central IT
team and the build team
was maintaining for these teams as well.
And because those cells are
super independent as well,
they, of course, had
quite a different-looking
build infrastructure as well,
which was part of the challenge here.
But let's go through the story.
So we have similar story,
we had a lot of zombies in the basement.
They were growing in the
dark, moist environment.
I don't know how they got there.
We're going to look how did
we go through getting them
quarantined basically,
what was the solution?
We look a little bit deeper
into the architectures,
just like Miranda did.
We do have a little bit different kind
of architecture though, so bear with me.
We'll look at the results
and then learnings
and what are we actually
going to build next.
But let's start for the infestation.
The on premises was all
Intel Macs back in 2023.
They were just going fine
in there in the darkness,
but there was a lot of problems
with the hardware itself.
So we didn't have to fly somewhere,
we had to just go downstairs,
but still it was taking
quite a lot of time
for our IT engineers just
reinstalling the Macs,
trying to troubleshoot them,
troubleshoot the hardware
and so on and so on.
Also, like with Riots, the
VMware was basically saying
that they're not going to be supporting
the ESXi on Mac hardware,
especially on the Mac,
the Apple Silicon.
They're not going to support that at all.
So we have to find some kind of solution.
How do we go on running our
build infrastructure as well?
And in worst days, it
could be that one-third
of the whole Mac fleet, we
had multiple, multiple racks
of this hardware was
actually not operable at all.
So our game teams, those
sales were suffering,
because the build times were
getting longer and longer,
they had a lot of builds in the queue,
so it was causing quite
a lot of problem as well.
And at the same time,
while we had one-third
of the fleet broken, they wanted more.
We had new game teams popping up.
They wanted to be able to
develop, sign, build their games
and also the game teams
themselves, the live games,
something like Brawl
Stars and Clash Royale,
they were growing, they to do more build.
So we had a whole conflict, this friction
of broken hardware and, at the same time,
high demand for new things.
So we had either option.
One option was that we started looking,
do we start building a
data center somewhere
to actually get out from the basement?
But then we remembered back
in 2023 that a wise man
had told us friends don't let
friends build data centers.
This is a quote from 2013,
it's still valid on 2023
and it's still valid today as well.
So instead, we did go with
looking at the EC2 Mac,
which already had launched
at that point, as said,
multiple years earlier.
But we, in Supercell,
hadn't looked at them
until the MAC instances actually
became available on EC2 Mac
or the Apple Silicon instances.
So our solution is based
on these four pillars
that, basically, the weapons that we use
to start slaying the
zombies in the basement.
First off, of course I said, EC2 Mac,
getting, especially
the Apple Silicon ones,
running right out of gate.
So that would actually a,
improve the performance
like we saw from Miranda's numbers
and also we don't have to
go to the basement anymore.
We can actually look into
the sky and to the clouds
and just maintain it that way.
Unlike the Riot Games,
we actually ended up
using virtualization
on top of the EC2 Mac.
I'll go into details why,
but we use Cirrus Labs'
Tart virtualization,
which is based on the Apple's official
virtualization framework.
So it's actually using Apple's
own macOS native virtualization
to actually spawn officially
supported virtual macOS
on top of the Mac hardware as well.
The reason for that is
that the EC2 Mac still have
that if you switch the AMI,
it has this scrubbing dime
that takes quite a while
for that to go round.
There is, of course, now the
quick replacement mechanism
as well, but back when
we started developing
this solution, that was not available yet.
So we went with the virtualization
and the benefit of that
is that we can actually
really quickly switch between
different Tart VM images,
which more or less
behave, if you're familiar
with containers, it behaves
like containers as well.
So you can quickly start
the machine as well.
On top of that, of
course, we use Terraform
to manage this whole infrastructure
and we use the Packer to create
those Tart VM images as well.
And last part, the fourth pillar is,
I'm not going to pronounce this correct,
it's, I guess, French, Mise-en-place.
So it's a nice tool that
you can use to define
what kind of tools you
want to have installed
in the operating system itself.
So you can list it I want
this version of Xcode,
I want this version of
whatever other tools
that you want to use, like
AWS SDK, you can list those
and then just run the mise-en-place
to customize the image on the fly.
And this happens on every build actually.
So when a build starts
running, the mise-en-place
customizes quickly the machine on the fly,
just before the build
itself starts as well.
And lastly, what I want
to maybe mention also
why the Amazon EC2 Mac
was natural for Supercell
is that Supercell actually
born in the cloud.
So when we were founded 2010,
already everything was
build on AWS as well.
So we had years and
years of AWS experience
and especially really good
experience on using EC2
and all the other
surrounding services as well.
But then let's look
how did we actually put
these tools, these pillars in the work?
Well, everyone's familiar,
we had AWS Region,
we had the VPC and multiple AZs as well.
And on top of that, we have
the Auto Scaling Group.
What is kinda special with the EC2 Mac,
concerning Auto Scaling
Group, is that if you only put
an Auto Scaling Group
in place, it won't work.
And the reason for that is that EC2 Mac
are actually dedicated hosts.
So you actually have to go in
and provision a dedicated host
and then on top of that,
you can go and provision an EC2 instance.
So there's like an extra
lifecycle step here,
but luckily, AWS has another service
that can help you manage the relationship
with the Auto Scaling Group instances
and the physical on-demand
machines as well.
And that is the AWS License Manager.
It's maybe not directly clear
to you why it does that,
but the License Manager has a feature
called Host Resource Group,
So it can actually
automatically provision you
on-demand machines based on
the Auto Scaling Group saying
that I need a new hardware to run on.
And then this License Manager goes in
and actually provisions
the machine for you.
What is really neat about it as well
is that if you don't have
any instance running on that,
on demand machine for a while,
it will try to get rid
of it as well for you.
And with EC2 Mac, that means
that after the 24 hours,
it's gone, which is the
Apple-demanded minimum time
to have the on-demand
machine allocated to you.
The License Manager will make sure
that that gets thrown away and basically,
the cost for that Mac instance
will stop at that, not instance,
but the dedicated host
will stop at that point.
And the magical glue there, how you attach
the Auto Scaling Group
to the License Manager
is through the EC2 Launch Template.
In there, you're basically saying
I want to use host resource group
to be the source of the hardware
for this Auto Scaling Group.
And then later on, because
we ended up licensing also
the Tart virtualization
engine, which is open source,
but if you want to have official support,
you can license it as well,
the License Manager is
a nice way to make sure
that we never go above
the number of licenses
that we have purchased as well.
So it actually came pretty
handy for us as well.
But then let's go forward.
Now, we can get those physical
machines, those EC2 Mac,
so it will launch an EC2
instance and we just use
those out-of-the-box default
AMIs that AWS provides us.
We don't actually do any
customization of them
in terms of AMI.
We do use the user data though
and what the user data does
is when we launch, for
example now the latest AMI
from AWS, the user data
will actually make sure
that the Cirrus Lab Tart gets installed
and then it quickly kicks in
the image that we want to kick in
on top of that EC2 instance as well.
So in the user data, that
we just quickly launch
a virtual machine.
And in that virtual machine,
what comes out of the image,
the Tart VM image that we custom built
with the Terraform Packer,
it has several things.
It has, first of all, it
has the GitHub actions
and it has the GitHub access runner
and it has the Jenkins agent.
That's because we are
now in the transition
from Jenkins to GitHub
actions more and more
per team, per those cells.
So each image has
support for both of them.
To make that decision
which one is being used,
we actually coded our
own little agent called
the coco agent, which is our
own little scripting code
as well, that it looks at
the metadata and then knows,
oh, I belong to this team,
this team uses Jenkins,
the Jenkins controller
is in this IP address.
I'm going to connect this there.
Or is it GitHub actions runner, it knows,
oh, this team is actually
using the runner,
let's connect to the github.com
to actually get the jobs
and add the machines into the queue.
Also into the image we have
built, of course, Xcode.
We have all the other command
line tools there as well
and any other default tooling you need
to do the signing and so on.
And of course, we have
the mise-en-pace in there
that the teams themselves can customize
whatever they want at the
runtime point as well.
So that's what's in here and
how does this all get built?
The Supercell Developer Services,
which is the team taking care
of the running of this environment,
they use GitHub access themself
with the Packer to the
build the Tart VM images.
Those VM images are then saved on EFS,
the Elastic File Storage, which is mounted
to the EC2 Mac instance
itself on the base layer macOS
and that's how the Tart can quickly switch
between any kind of Xcode versions,
macOS versions, et cetera, et cetera.
We have all of those different variations,
different combinations
built on the EFS storage,
allowing us to quickly take them into use.
Some scripts are stored in S3 as well.
And what's kind of unique for us as well
is that what you don't see
in this picture at all,
and it's actually missing, is
we don't have any EBS volume
other than the AMI locked into this,
because we use the local NVME storage
as the disk for the Tart VMs as well.
We could use EBS for it,
but we actually found that the EC2 Mac,
the NVME is really, really high performing
and as Vishal said, it is comes for free,
so why not use it as well?
So we're taking the full
advantage of that local NVME
to make the builds really, really snappy.
We also use the parameter
store to store any secrets,
like how do you sign the applications,
because all of our games are mobile games,
so all the time, we need to
sign them officially as well.
And also none of the
people have direct access
into the EC2 Mac or even the Tart VM.
I said we are running the
Tart VM on top of a macOS
and we do need to sometimes go
with the VNC inside the Tart VM
and how we achieve that
is that we actually use
the system manager to tunnel ourselves in
into the macOS itself.
So nothing is exposed
to the outside world.
You have to have AWS
access and you have to have
the permissions given to
you through the SSM and IAM
to be able to even connect
to the machine itself.
So this is how we run overall
the whole infrastructure.
And we do use the CloudWatch logs
and the CloudWatch metrics
to get basic stuff out.
But on top of that, our guys
in the Developer Services
are also using Telegraf and Open Telemetry
to get really detailed tracing
of how long does each
stage of the build take
and what kind of things
happen there as well.
And that is something we
have developed in-house.
So we are using both CloudWatch
and we are using Grafana Prometheus
to kinda have our own metrics as well.
And this is how we run
majority of the build farm now
for building our games for
iPhone, for iPad and so on,
is run by this Auto Scaling Group.
There are some standalone machines as well
for really, really corner cases
where they actually need to
get the hardware directly.
For example, if they need the
GPU, we cannot use the Tart VM
because GPUs are not exposed directly
into the virtual machine itself.
So we have some cases of even
standalone machines as well.
So after we got this solution running,
our house, our life after
the zombie apocalypse
was dealt with, we did
manage to escape basement.
I think we only have
few of those Intel Macs
still running in there for
some really old build shops,
because we still have some developers
who still believe in the
Intel MacBook pros as well.
So we kind have to still have couple
of Intel-based builders
just for those guys
until we can convince them to move
towards the Apple Silicon as well.
We do use the Auto Scaling Group
so we have now an automation
that every weekend,
we shed the load, we scale down
to minimum number of machines as well
and then on Monday or actually nowadays,
bit also on the Sunday side,
we start scaling up the fleet of builders.
So we can get some cost
optimization into play as well.
At least our IT is really aesthetic,
because they don't have to go
to the basement anymore at all
and go and give some
daylight into the Macs
and switch the cable around
and now it works type of thing.
So we actually reduced
the operational overhead significantly.
There used to be like
multiple guys from IT
just going downstairs
to do the physical work
on fixing the Macs.
Now we just have basically one person
in taking care of the whole
thousands of machines on AWS,
which is a really, really
good improvement as well.
And in terms of numbers, I don't have
as detailed numbers as Miranda had,
but even for us, we now
have 10x more build shops
than before taking this solution into use.
But we only had three times
the number of Macs needed as well.
So that is a really,
really good, good result,
at least from our point of view.
And also considering that one
person is maintaining this.
We used to have 150 build shops per day
on max in the basement in the zombieland
and nowadays in the cloud,
we have over 1,800 builds happening daily.
So as you can see, there's
quite a lot of growth
that we were able to
achieve with this solution.
And also now we can, a lot quicker, take,
which is not on the list here,
but we can take new EC2, not EC2
but we can take new versions of the macOS
into use quite quickly as well,
because everything is virtualized,
so we can, even without updating
the underlying MAC host itself,
we can, in the Tart VM, already switch
to the latest and
greatest version of macOS,
even before the official
AMI is released as well.
So what did we learn in this journey
in the last two to three years?
In the beginning back in 2023,
a lot of this stuff was
completely undocumented.
There was no prior
experience on how to use the-
Well, there was some
experience on the EC2 Mac,
but because we wanted to
do the virtualization,
that was more or less no documentation.
So there was a lot of trial
and error of figuring out
how the Tart VMs worked
in production as well.
Also, as I said, the macOS,
Apple can always give us
a really, really, a lot of curve balls
in terms of the macOS updates as well.
So when we try the new version,
that has crippled like,
"Oh, there's a new security
feature that we have to glow
and click on every machine
to enable it as well."
And it has helped us that
we have worked closely
with Vishal and our AWS account team
to plan out our capacity as well.
We are mostly European-based
with some studios also
in Shanghai and also in North America.
It has helped us immensely
to communicate clearly that,
oh, we're going to need this
many Mac machines as well.
So that has helped us to go forward,
but overall, we can say
that it's not cheap solution
and overall, the EC2 Mac
are not the cheapest
instance types available.
First off, being
dedicated host, of course,
but neither is the manual
work we were doing downstairs.
I said we went for, let's say,
five to seven people maintaining
this environment in the basement
to just one-and-a-half
people basically maintaining
this bigger environment into the cloud.
So for us overall, it was
still a win-win situation
and it had a huge impact
and unlocked a lot of things
in the game teams themselves
to be able to develop faster,
try new things faster as well.
And then let's look at what
is the future bringing us
beyond the zombie apocalypse.
So what are we building next?
We are really excited of the new M4s
and the two terabyte local NVMEs,
because it allows us to
make the images bigger.
The old machines had 256 gigabytes of disc
and if you look at any kind
of modern game building,
luckily, we're a mobile game company,
we can still fit into that,
but I would imagine a
lot of like Riot Games,
they're not going to fit into 256 gigs
to build anything at all.
She's shaking her head.
So we're kinda lucky
with the mobile games,
they're reasonably smaller
than your average PC game
or console game as well.
But we're still looking
forward for the two terabytes,
because that would unlock
us, for the first time,
to run two VMs per physical EC2 Mac.
So we're basically going to
be able to double our capacity
without any extra cost as well
using the VM approach here.
What we don't have right now as well
is we don't have fully
dynamic auto scaling.
Right now, it's basically on calendar,
so it knows that every Monday,
it must scale up to this number
and every Friday, it has to scale down.
But in the future, we will have,
through the coco agent
that was shown there,
we will have dynamic following
of the size of the queues.
So we'll be able to automatically,
with our own little coordinator tool,
to deploy new machines
and retire them quickly
if the queue size of the
builds is at zero for example.
And in general, this has also now unlocked
the people to do more work
on the actual improvement
of the pipelines themselves
instead of trying to do the
troubleshooting day to day
on the fleet as well.
So there will be better pipelines coming
and we going to be now be able to extend
with all the automation
in place, the Terraforms,
the Packers and all this stuff,
we can now easily expand
it to new regions as well.
For example, we are now
deploying it in US as well,
because we have couple of
game teams now based in US
in Seattle and and Los Angeles.
We can now quickly, with the
already built Terraforms,
just bring up the whole
environment for them in US as well
that they can have quick
and snappy builds in US.
So lastly, on the zombie team, it's like,
"They're coming for you, Barbara,"
so if you're not careful,
the zombie apocalypse
can also happen to you
if you're still stuck
on your Intel Mac somewhere
in the basement or closet,
hiding in the dark corners of the world.
Excellent, I'm going to
actually hand it back to Vishal
and he's going to tell you
more about what else is coming
in terms of the EC2 Mac presentations,
but other than that, you survived
the zombie apocalypse
with me and thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.
(audience clapping continues)
Awesome.
Before we wrap up here guys,
thank you so much for spending
time with us here today.
Thank you to Toni and
Miranda for working with me
through the multiple months that we've had
to put this together.
Before I let you guys go,
I did want to tell you
what else to expect at re:Invent
for EC2 Mac and just macOS in general.
So first thing is, as I've
hinted, please make sure
to not miss our AWS
CEO's keynote tomorrow.
Matt Garman will be speaking,
I believe, at around 8:00 AM
up until 10:30, so please tune in
for some exciting news on EC2
Mac during his presentations.
Secondly, we do have a few sessions
that I wanted to call out
and make sure that they're on your radar.
So the first one is going to be actually
on Wednesday, the third.
The ID is CMP 306 and that
one is actually going to be
a hands-on workshop where you
guys can actually play around
with a lot of the features
that we talked about today,
such as system integrity
protection, replace root volume.
And so super excited to
actually get your laptops out
and actually play around with that
and two of my colleagues will
be presenting that as well.
On the same day, we have another session
that's called CMP 346 and this
one is actually really cool,
'cause it's the first time
we're gonna be talking
about how we can do ML and
inference using EC2 Mac
and the amazing GPU power
that comes with Apple Silicon
and some of my colleagues
are going to be presenting
on that as well.
It's the first time that we're going
to be talking about running actual ML
and inference workloads
using Apple Silicon chips.
So make sure not to miss that.
Then if you want to see me again,
I'll be talking at CMP 344,
which is again on Wednesday.
And that is actually, me and my colleague
will actually go through
and actually do a live demo
on using EC2 Mac and GitHub
actions or GitLab CircleCI,
whatever automation tool that you guys use
and he'll actually be going through
and running an actual build
change using a live demo Xcode
to see how it actually runs on EC2 Mac
and you'll be able to see the live change
on his test flight app that
we'll be screen-sharing as well.
So three other sessions that
I encourage you guys to join
as well as Matt Garman's keynote tomorrow
and any of the other keynotes as well.
So with that being said,
I think a few of us
will hang around if
you have any questions,
but thank you so much for coming
and please make sure to
complete the session survey
in the app as well, thank you.
(audience clapping)